un raid 100 pour 100 étudiants entre la
vallée de chevreuse et rambouillet c'est
la promesse de l'association étudiante
centrale supélec
la structure organise cette année la
première édition du sac les night and
day cette compétition proposera un trail
de nuit de 12 km ce vendredi 17 février
au départ de la gare de courcelles sur
yvette
ces secours par équipe de 4 mixte on a
des concurrents étudiants
majoritairement également des
entreprises partenaires dont qui courent
également sur l'événement le principe
c'est que le vendredi soir il y à un
trail de nuit de 13 km donc les
concurrents partent de la gare rer de
conseil sur yvette et des barres aux
flambeaux et ensuite voilà il ya un
tracé de 13 km qui doivent suivre à la
frontale
le lendemain les concurrents vont se
retrouver autour du château de
rambouillet sur un parcours modulable en
vtt et à pied
en parallèle de la course des animations
multisports sont proposés dans un
village sportif
en marge de la crosse il ya du big air
bag des choses que des mini-jeux lancer
de buch d'une de leurs trappes
donc c'est un festival trappe avec un
arc donc plein d'activités comme ça en
marge de la course c'est un événement
qui se veut vraiment à la fois
accessible aux personnes très très
sportive qui veulent vraiment faire de
la performance et aux personnes qui
veulent juste passer une bonne journée
entre amis
cette année le rendez-vous affiche
complet plus de 400 étudiants se sont
inscrits pour l'événement
[Musique]